PARTNERS, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
NOTHING BUT A MERE EXTENSION.
AND THE MAN WHO WAS EXPOSING ALL
OF THIS, WELL, HE'S OUT WITH A
BRAND NEW BOOK.
HE'S THE HOST OF A NUMBER ONE
SHOW RIGHT HERE ON THE FOX NEWS
CHANNEL ON SUNDAY NIGHT, THE
HOST OF LIFE, LIBERTY, AND
LEVINE.
HE'S GOT HIS NATIONALLY
SYNDICATED SHOW, THERE'S THE
AUTHOR RIGHT THERE.
UNFREEDOM OF THE PRESS.
MY BROTHER, HOW ARE YOU?
>> GOD BLESS YOU, BRO, HOW ARE
YOU?
>> YOU KNOW, WHAT I LOVE ABOUT
YOUR BOOKS, I MEAN LIBERTY,
TYRANNY, EVERYTHING YOU GO
THROUGH SUCH DETAIL, HISTORICAL
DETAIL.
BEFORE I GET TO THE IDIOTS, YOU
DO TALK ABOUT THE PRESS IN THE
PAST AND YOU TALK ABOUT HOW THEY
TREATED JEFFERSON, THE BRUTAL
BATTLE BETWEEN QUINCY ADAMS AND
HAMILTON, I MEAN, THAT WENT
ON -- THE LEGEND IN SOME WAYS.
BUT TODAY IS VERY DIFFERENT.
SO, MY FIRST QUESTION IS WHY DID
YOU WANT THAT CONTEXT IN HISTORY
THERE?
>> FIRST, I WANTED THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS IS THEIR
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS.
IT DOESN'T BELONG TO CNN.
IT DOESN'T BELONG TO MSNBC.
FREE SPEECH, FREEDOM OF THE
PRESS.
THEY'RE BOTH IN THE FIRST
AMENDMENT FOR A REASON.
THIS COUNTRY WAS STARTED, IT WAS
THE PAMPHLETEERS, A HANDFUL OF
NEWSPAPER MEN, THE PRINTERS, THE
GREAT, GREAT PRESENCE.
THEY PUSHED THE IDEAS.
THEY TALKED ABOUT PHILOSOPHERS
LIKELOCK AND --
>> WHICH YOU HAVE DONE IN YOUR
PAST BOOKS.
>> WHICH I HAD DONE.
THESE WERE THE PEOPLE, THE
PRINTING PRESS.
THEY WERE ONLY A FEW.
THEY MOVED THEM FROM TIME TO
TIME BECAUSE THE BRITISH WERE
TRYING TO HUNT THEM DOWN.
THEY PUSHED THESE IDEAS.
THERE WERE MANY OTHERS, THOMAS
PAINE, PEOPLE WOULD READ THESE,
TALK ABOUT THEM AT THEIR PUBS,
THEIR HOMES, THEIR DINNER TABLE,
AND WORD WOULD SPREAD.
COMMON SENSE, THOMAS PAINE'S
PAMPHLET, ESTIMATED 120,000
PEOPLE READ IT.
IT'S A COUNTRY OF ABOUT 2
MILLION PEOPLE.
AND BE I THE TIME IT WAS OVER,
HALF A MILLION PEOPLE HAD READ
IT.
IT HAD ENORMOUS INFLUENCE.
WHY WAS IT IMPORTANT?
BACK THEN, WHAT IF OUR PRESS --
THEY DIDN'T CALL THEMSELVES A
PRESS, WHAT DID THE PRESS DO?
PROMOTED LIBERTY, INDIVIDUALISM,
REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT,
PRIVATE PROPERTY RIGHTS, LOW
TAXES AND SO FORTH.
AND THEN FROM THAT PERIOD, SOON
THERE AFTER, WE HAD A PARTY
PRESS.
AND IT WAS BRUTAL.
AND THE PRESS WOULD AT LEAST BE
TRANSPARENT.
THEY WOULD IDENTIFY WITH THE
POLITICAL PARTY, WITH THE
CANDIDATE, WITH THE CAUSE.
AND THOMAS JEFFERSON AND JOHN
ADAMS WOULD DUKE IT OUT.
SOME OF THE PEOPLE IN THE PRESS
WERE ON THE PAYROLL OF THE
POLITICAL PARTY AND SO FORTH.
BUT THEY WERE ALL OPEN ABOUT IT.
AGAIN, IS IT VERY, VERY UGLY?
YOU MOVE INTO A PERIOD OF -- AND
THAT LASTED FROM ABOUT 1780 TO
THE CIVIL WAR.
LET'S JUMP FORWARD TO THE EARLY
PART OF THE LAST CENTURY, THE
PROGRESSIVE MOVEMENT.
WELL, THEY DEVOURED MUCH OF OUR
GOVERNMENT, THE IDEOLOGY DID.
IT DOES TODAY.
THEY WANTED TO PROFESSIONALIZE
IT.
THEY WANTED STANDARDS.
THEY SAID WE NEEDED TO BE MORE
OBJECTIVE.
BUT, THEY SAID, WE NEED TO --
YOU KNOW, WE NEED TO HAVE A
HANDFUL OF ELITES, A HANDFUL OF
PEOPLE WHO UNDERSTAND THE
COUNTRY AND THE WORLD THROUGH
WHICH ALL OF THIS WILL BE
LAUNDERED, WHICH IS THE WAY THEY
VIEW GOVERNMENT TOO.
THE PEOPLE ARE STUPID, THEY'RE
PLEBES, TOO BUSY, TOO IGNORANT.
LET US TELL THEM WHAT TO THINK.
TODAY'S MEDIA, THAT'S THEIR
HERITAGE, THEY'VE TAKEN IT A
STEP FURTHER.
THEY'RE SOCIAL ACTIVISTS.
THEY'RE BEING TAUGHT THIS IN
JOURNALISM SCHOOL.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO REPORT THE
FACTS.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO BE OBJECTIVE.
THEY ARGUE, WHATEVER THAT MEANS.
WE HAVE TO PUSH AN AGENDA.
SOME OF THEM ARE OUT OF THE
CLOSET AND THEY ADMIT THAT WE
NEED TO PUSH THE LIBERAL AND
PROGRESSIVE AGENDA.
SOME OF THEM, WHEN YOU CHALLENGE
THEM, THEY SAY YOU EAR ATTACKING
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS.
AND THEY PRETEND THAT THEY'RE
STILL OBJECTIVE WHEN THEY'RE
NOT.
SURVEY AFTER SURVEY, STUDY AFTER
STUDY SHOWS HALF OF THE COUNTRY,
THE VAST MAJORITY OF
REPUBLICANS, THE VAST MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE WHO LEAN CONSERVATIVE
OR ARE CONSERVATIVE, DO NOT
TRUST THE MEDIA.
THERE'S A REASON FOR IT.
ANOTHER HALF DO.
DEMOCRATS, LIBERALS THINK THE
MEDIA IS PRETTY DARN GOOD.
SO, WHEN YOU LOSE THE TRUST OF
HALF OF THE COUNTRY, YOU'RE NOT
DOING YOUR JOB.
AND THEY'RE NOT DOING THEIR JOB.
THEY PLAY TO A NICHE.
IN EVEN THE WORD OBJECTIVE IS
DEBATED.
OBJECTIVE IN THE TERMS OF THE
THE JOURNALISTS OR THE PROCESS?
SO THEY PRETTY MUCH SURRENDERED
THAT.
YOU KNOW, A COUPLE OF MONTHS
AGO, CHUCK TODD ON "MEET THE
PRESS" HE DECLARED THAT MAN MADE
CLIMATE CHANGE IS A FACT.
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO ALLOW
DENIERS ON "MEET THE PRESS."
HE'S MORE THAN THE HOST.
HE'S THE CHIEF POLITICAL GURU
FOR THE ENTIRE NBC NETWORK.
>> Sean: YOU SEEM TO HAND HIM A
WHOLE SO-CALLED NEWS CHANNEL
THAT'S A CONSPIRACY CHANNEL.
>> MSNBC.
>> Sean: LIKE ROZWELL, NEW
MEXICO OVER THERE.
>> CHUCK TODD DOESN'T KNOW THE
FIRST THING ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE.
YOU'RE A PHYSICIST, PhD.S, CLIMB
DIALOGISTS, METEOROLOGISTS, NOT
JUST HUNDREDS OF THEM, THOUSANDS
OF THEM DEBATE MAN MADE CLIMATE
CHANGE, DEBATE IF IT EXISTS.
HE HAS DECLARED WE'RE NOT GOING
TO ALLOW THAT ON OUR SHOW.
THAT DEMONSTRATES TO YOU, HE'S
PUSHING THE AGENDA.
THE WHOLE RUSSIA CONCLUSIO
THE WHOLE RUSSIA COLLLUSIO
THE WHOLE RUSSIA COLLUSSIO
THE WHOLE RUSSIA COLLUSIOO
THE WHOLE RUSSIA COLLUSION
THICK.
THE NOTION OF NEWS VERSUS
PROPAGANDA VERSUS PSEUDOEVENTS.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS ON TO SOMETHING.
WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT FAKE NEWS,
THERE WAS A BRILLIANT HISTORIAN,
THE UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO,
DANIEL BORSTEIN, HE BECAME THE
HEAD OF THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS,
HE WROTE A BOOK ON PSEUDOEVENTS.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE NEWS
AMONG OTHER THINGS.
THEY CREATE THEIR OWN REALITY,
HOW THEY CHOOSE EVENTS, CREATE
EVENTS, HOW JOURNALISTS PROMOTE
THEMSELVES THROUGH DRAMA, YOU
CAN SEE WITH JIM ACOSTA WHO
CREATES CONDITIONS WHERE THE
FOCUS IS ON HIM AND NOT -- THIS
IS AN ENORMOUS DISSERVICE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
PSEUDONEWS.
RUSSIA COLLUSION WITH THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
2 1/2 YEARS OF SUE DOE -- AS THE
PRESIDENT CALLS IT, FAKE NEWS.
AND PSEUDONEWS REQUIRES MORE
PSEUDONEWS.
OBSTRUCTION, A PSEUDOEVENT, IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN, BUT THEY CLAIM
IT.
700 FORMER PROSECUTORS WRITING A
LETTER, ALL LIBERALS, THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF FORMER PROSECUTORS,
ANOTHER PSEUDOEVENT.
PHONY SUBPOENAS THAT ARE
INTENDED TO GATHER INFORMATION
THAT WON'T DO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ANY GOOD, THAT HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH CONGRESSIONAL
OVERSIGHT.
PSEUDOEVENTS.
THIS IMPEACHMENT DEBATE,
ABSOLUTELY PHONY.
ANOTHER PSEUDOEVENT.
MEANWHILE, THERE'S ALL KINDS OF
EVENTS TAKING PLACE IN THE WORLD
AND IN THIS COUNTRY THAT ARE NOT
BEING COVERED BY NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS.
THERE'S SOME EXCEPTIONS.
BUT IN THE AGGREGATE, THIS IS
THE CONDITION WE FACE.
THIS IS AN ENORMOUS DISSERVICE
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
REMEMBER THIS.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT BELONGS TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE BILL OF RIGHTS, BELONGS TO
THE CONSTITUTION BELONGS TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHEN THEY SAY DONALD TRUMP IS
LIKE A DICTATOR BECAUSE HE CALLS
THE MEDIA OR MEDIA OUTLET OR
MEDIA PERSON THE ENIMY OF THE
PEOPLE, THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.
DONALD TRUMP POINTS OUT,
QUESTIONS THEM, IS HARSH IN HIS
RHETORIC, AND OUGHT TO BE.
AND HE HAVE ACOSTA IN A FEW
WEEKS GOING TO WRITE A BOOK AND
SAY WE BASICALLY HAVE NOT SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS, SEAN.
LET ME GIVE YOU A HISTORY
LESSON.
>> Sean: IT.
>>S IN THE BOOK.
>> ALL OF THIS IS IN THE BOOK.
LET ME GIVE YOU A HISTORY
LESSON.
>> Sean: THIS IS A VERY HARD
INTERVIEW FOR ME.
I'M -- BUT THIS IS HONESTLY, THE
AMOUNT OF WORK, BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN IN YOUR HOUSE WHEN YOU DO
THE BOOKS.
YOU SEE THEM STACKED UP.
IT'S AN ENTIRE TWO ROOMS FULL OF
BOOKS AND PAPERS AND I DON'T
KNOW HOW YOU DO IT.
BUT KEEP GOING, I JUST WANT
PEOPLE TO KNOW HOW MUCH HISTORY
IS IN THIS.
>> I'M A NERD, WHAT CAN I SAY?
>> Sean: WE NEED A LOT OF NERDS.
YOU MENTIONED THOMAS PAINE.
THINK ABOUT WHAT HE SAID, MARK
AND THIS HISTORY YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH.
GOVERNMENT IN ITS BEST STATE IS
BUT A NECESSARY EVIL AND IN THE
WORST STATE AN INTOLERABLE ONE.
BUT CONTINUE.
>> THE MEDIA SAYS DONALD TRUMP
IS THE GREATEST THREAT, OR SOME
OF THEM DO, TO FREEDOM OF THE
PRESS WE'VE EVER SEEN.
THAT IS A FLAT-OUT LIE.
THEY ARE HISTORICAL ILLITERATES.
LET'S START QUICKLY.
JOHN ADAMS, A GREAT FOUNDER, A
GREAT MAN AND WRITER ABOUT
LIBERTY AND ALL THINGS.
SO HE AND HIS PARTY PUT IN PLACE
THE SEDITION ACT.
IF YOU CRITICIZE THAT PRESIDENT,
YOU CRITICIZE HIS PARTY, YOU
CRITICIZE THE GOVERNMENT, HE HAS
THE POWER TO IMPRISON YOU.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
HE IMPRISONED SOME JOURNALISTS
AND HE SHUT DOWN SOME
NEWSPAPERS.
JEFFERSON WAS FURIOUS, HE WAS A
LIBERTARIAN.
HE RUNS AGAINST ADAMS, AMONG
OTHER THING, AGAINST THE ALIEN
AND SEDITION ACT.
HE WINS IN A BRUTAL CAMPAIGN.
I WON'T GET INTO ALL OF THE
DETAILS.
HE WINS.
HE GETS RID OF THE SEDITION ACT.
AND THE MEDIA ATTACK HIM AND
BRUTALIZE HIM.
AND SO THAT'S THE PARTY PRESS,
THE PARTY PRESS THAT SUPPORTED
ADAMS AND HAMILTON AND HIS PARTY
AND THAT PARTY, WOULD VICIOUSLY
ATTACK HIM.
AND HE WOULD STILL SAY, I'M NOT
GOING TO TOUCH IT.
ABRAHAM LINCOLN IN THE CIVIL WAR
THROUGH HIS SECRETARY WAR
STANDARD SHUT DOWN APPROXIMATELY
300 NEWSPAPERS.
AND IMPRISONED A SLEW OF
JOURNALISTS, AMONG OTHERS, AMONG
OTHERS.
BECAUSE THEY FELT LIKE WHATEVER
YOUR ARGUMENT IS, THEY FELT LIKE
THEY NEEDED TO BECAUSE OF THE
CIVIL WAR.
WOODROW WILSON, ONE OF THE GREAT
PROGRESSIVE INTELLECTUALS THAT
BECAME PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES ALMOST BY ACCIDENT, HE
WENT FURTHER.
HE PUT A NEW ACT IN PLACE IN
1918.
AND AN EXTENSION OF THE
ESPIONAGE ACT, WE'RE FAMILIAR
WITH THAT.
WHAT HE AND HIS PARTY DID IS
THEY WENT AFTER JOURNALISTS THEY
DISAGREED WITH.
THEY WENT AFTER POLITICAL
OPPONENTS.
THEY PUT HIM IN JAIL.
HE PUT IN PLACE AN EXTENSIVE
CENSORSHIP CAMPAIGN AND
PROPAGANDA CAMPAIGN, THE GREAT
PROGRESSIVE.
FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT TURNED THE
IRS ON NEWSPAPERS HE DISAGREED
WITH.
THE OWNER OF THE ENQUIRER WAS
INVESTIGATED BY THE IRS BY HIS
DIRECTION.
GANNETT WAS INVESTIGATED AT THE
DIRECTION OF ELEANOR ROOSEVELT.
SO THEY WOULD USE THE IRS.
KENNEDY DID TOO.
BARACK OBAMA.
THIS IS RECENT HISTORY.
THE FBI, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, WENT AFTER THE NEW YORK
TIMES.
TO -- JAMES RISEN, WENT AFTER
JAMES ROSEN OF THIS NETWORK.
WENT AFTER 20 REPORTERS OF THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS.
BARACK OBAMA.
DONALD TRUMP HADN'T DONE ANY OF
THESE THINGS TO.
CALL HIM THE GREATEST THREAT TO
THE PRESS IS AN OUTRAGE.
>> THIS IS A PRIMER THIS, IS ALL
IN THE BOOK.
THE HISTORY IS PHENOMENAL.
THEY EVEN BRING UP PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTIONS CHARGES OF BIGAMY AND
DUELLING.
YOU SHOW THIS HISTORY.
IT'S FASCINATING TO SEE HOW IT
HAS EVOLVED BUT I WANT TO BRING
IT TO CURRENT DAY.
I DO BELIEVE THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S BRANDING OF FAKE
NEWS WILL FOREVER BE TATTOOED ON
THEIR FOREHEADS BECAUSE OF HOW
LOW THEY HAD SUNK.
THE BOOK IS PHENOMENAL.
UNFREEDOM OF THE PRESS.
WE CONTINUE WITH THE GREAT ONE,
MARK LEVINE.
WHEN WE COME BACK, THE MEDIA'S